fue un momento de intensa emoción este
miércoles el Papa Francisco se reunió
con un grupo de víctimas de violencia
del este de la República democrática del
Congo en donde hay más de 120 grupos
armados el papa escuchó las dramáticas
historias de estas personas torturadas
violadas hombres mujeres y niños que
vieron morir a sus seres queridos
Francisco les envió un mensaje de
Consuelo sus Lágrimas son mis lágrimas
dijo el sumo pontífice quien condenó las
masacres las violaciones la ocupación de
los pueblos los saqueos Ya basta
silencien las armas y pongan fin a la
guerra clamó el papa contra los
violentos el pontífice invitó a toda la
sociedad congoleña a responder al mal
con el bien al odio con el amor durante
el encuentro las víctimas presentes se
comprometieron a perdonar a sus verdugos
un gesto simbólico a través del cual el
papa espera animar a toda la sociedad
congoleña a la reconciliación